[Musica]
la nostra vita sulla terra è sempre più
dipendente dallo spazio è come si dice
space based
quanto entra lo spazio nella vita di
ognuno di noi proviamo a capirlo con
esempi pratici
provate a pensare alle 23 applicazioni
che avete usato prima di venire qui nel
teatro di modena ci sono quelli tra di
voi che hanno guardato la meteo quelli
che hanno pagato il parcheggio nella
vita qui dietro utilizzando una mappa
che costruita con almeno 100 satelliti o
quelli che hanno messo il navigatore per
venire fin qui
quindi se oggi così ad occhio qui siamo
più o meno 300 significa che in qualche
secondo solo toccando il nostro
smartphone abbiamo processato più di
mille volte dati provenienti da fratelli
ti di almeno tre tipologie diverse
mentre un po più nel concreto
questa sera quando andrete a letto sono
sicura che molti di voi hanno un
materasso in memoria di forma è stato
disegnato la prima volta per gli
astronauti oggi lo comprate al centro
commerciale o anche in linea
per quelli di voi che fanno bricola
recente sabato la domenica
trapani e aspiratori senza fili sono il
frutto della collaborazione tra la nasa
e un noto industriale del settore per
poter fornire strumenti utilizzabili
sulla luna nell'ambito della missione
apollo
eco fin dall'inizio le tecnologie
spaziali hanno avuto delle ricadute
sulla nostra vita quotidiana
dalle tute ignifughe dei pompieri che
derivano da quelle degli astronauti fino
alla cultura dei self i
difensori ideati per la prima volta
negli anni 90 dalla nasa per poter
miniaturizzare le telecamere su sonde
interplanetarie oggi sono installati nei
nostri smartphone
fino alle condizioni critiche estreme
che si trovano nello spazio e che ci
permettono di studiare fenomeni come
l'invecchiamento del corpo umano o di
osservare in maniera molto più ricca il
comportamento di cellule e proteine
responsabili di malattie come la
sindrome di parkinson
ecco io nella mia vita mi occupo di
lanciarli quegli oggetti i satelliti e
moduli orbitanti che poi ci renderanno
tutti questi servizi
ed eccolo il mio lanciatore
è un misti lotto di 800 tonnellate che
porta satelliti in orbita e lo
costruiamo facendo lavorare insieme e
centinaia di aziende e ognuno deve
ritrovare in questa sfida tecnologica il
proprio tornaconto strategico ed
economico
e così noi intendo noi creiamo un vero
proprio il cui sistema una vera e
propria economia dello spazio a cui
tutti contribuiamo attraverso i fondi
europei per esempio con una spesa media
pro capite calcolata di circa 20 euro
l'anno
e da qualche anno noi ingegneri spaziali
passiamo dall'essere degli specialisti
del settore anche un po secchioni
diciamo no al essere catapultati sulla
scena mondiale sotto i riflettori da
quando uomini visionari come il on
mascot jeff bezos vedono nello spazio la
prossima frontiera dell'azione dell'uomo
e lo spazio è esattamente questo
non è un caso che il 40 per cento dei
top capitalist del mondo ovvero dei
fondi d'investimento più importanti al
mondo investano in tecnologie spaziali
questi investitori stanno benissimo che
le tecnologie
sofisticate che vengono sviluppate per
lo spazio avranno poi ricadute in
diversi comparti sulla terra dalla
salute alla difesa ai trasporti
all'ambiente alle telecomunicazioni
e allora c'è chi come me mangia spazio
tutti i giorni e sempre più ce ne sarà
chi di voi non ha detto almeno una volta
da piccolo di voler fare l'astronauta
alzate le mani ho bisogno di di capire e
di vedere di quantificare
e tante mani tante mani modena non non
mi stupisce voi terra di motori di
velocità
dell'astronauta maurizio cheli e di un
altro fenomeno spaziale vasco rossi
eros marco
ecco io avevo tre anni la prima volta
che lo dissi l'ho detto alla mia sua ora
l'ho fatto una testa così e poi l'ho
fatta a tutti quelli che sono venuti
dietro perché una passione così non tira
levi da addosso io il tatuaggio cielo
nel cervello
e anche se ne ho visti tanti ormai di
lanciatore partire per me ogni volta è
un'emozione
guardate
[Musica]
quando lanciammo io sono a 10 chilometri
eppure da terra trema sotto i miei piedi
e ogni volta
io parto con lui mi stacco da terra
attraverso l'atmosfera mi stabilito in
orbita così come il satellite che ci
abbiamo appena messo e guardo la terra
dalla sua
bella la terra da lassù e blu e calma e
trasparente
sì perché quando la osservi dello spazio
la terra non ha confini geopolitici non
è interpretabile il segnale l'immagine
che viene dal satellite e obiettivo è
veritiero
per questo in gergo diciamo trasparente
osservare la terra dallo spazio ci
permette di capire come vengono
utilizzate le risorse naturali ed ha un
impatto fondamentale
sulle soluzioni che verranno prese per
poter risolvere le sfide economiche
sociali ambientali che l'umanità dovrà
affrontare nei prossimi decenni
osservare la terra dallo spazio è già
parte della soluzione per risolverli
questi problemi
la scienza invece di dati satellitari di
immagini satellitari non ci permette di
analizzare in maniera obiettiva
se le decisioni prese o non prese da
certi stati per risolvere queste queste
schede sono state adeguate o meno
ecco rinforzata la centralità delle
tecnologie spaziali che influiscono a
che sulle relazioni internazionali
lo spazio è lo strumento fondamentale
per misurare gli obiettivi dello
sviluppo eco sostenibile
quelli dedicati alla lotta contro la
fame nel mondo
all accesso all'acqua potabile
all'agricoltura sostenibile al consumo
responsabile alla protezione della fauna
della flora all'accesso all'informazione
alla lotta contro i cambiamenti
climatici
e vi faccio una confessione
a me fa malissimo sapere che ci sono
vite umane perse
in catastrofi naturali come gli tsunami
in esodi incontrollati sapere che ci
sono donne in bangladesh che devono
raccogliere l'acqua dalle foglie la
mattina perché non hanno accesso alle
risorse naturali o queste non sono
correttamente sfruttate
mi fa male perché sono condizioni umane
che spesso possono
risolversi proprio grazie a quegli
oggetti che io contribuisco mandare
nello spazio
e lo spazio anche un luogo duale ovvero
dove gli interessi civili e militari si
incontrano non è un caso che le più
grandi potenze mondiali investano
ingenti somme di denaro nello sviluppo
di tecnologie spaziali
gli stati uniti 60 miliardi l'anno la
cina va oltre 100 miliardi
alcuni di questi paesi sono arrivati
fino a creare delle forze armate e
spaziali perché
vi risponderò raccontandovi un aneddoto
prima però vorrei precisare che il
concetto di vicinanza nello spazio si
intende in centinaia di chilometri due
oggetti nello spazio sono vicini quando
sono a centinaia di chilometri l'uno
dall'altro
nel 2017 due oggetti sono stati
osservati molto vicini nello spazio a
qualche decina di chilometri l'uno
dall'altro
o forse dovrei dire che uno si è molto
avvicinato all'altro perché dirlo così
cambia tutto
perché quando uno ascolta quello che
dice l'altro con il suo satellite di
fatto lo controlla
questo evento ha cambiato il modo in cui
vediamo lo spazio che passa dall'essere
un ambito scientifico
affascinante a terreno strategico
prima lo era il mare
coloro che avevano flotte potenti e ben
organizzate dominavano i mari decidevano
per se stessi e per gli altri oggi a
conferire questo potere è lo spazio
ecco perché lo spazio diventa una meta
così ambita perché innesca la gara
globale per influenzare il destino
altrui
allora in conclusione vi dico che la
nostra vita è molto dipendente da tutte
quelle tecnologie quelle ecosistema che
sta creando a migliaia di chilometri
sopra le nostre teste e sarebbe un
errore pensare che lo spazio è bello sì
ma insomma
quanto a che fare poi con la mia vita
quotidiana non solo entra tutti i giorni
nella vostra vita quotidiana
il materasso l'applicazione per pagare
il parcheggio il trapano
ma influenza anche le nostre relazioni
con gli altri popoli in base
all'osservazione
che potremmo farne dallo spazio il
libero accesso allo spazio il libero uso
dello spazio che è un bene comune per
definizione ci riguarda tutti
allora a stasera quando è rientrata a
casa prendete il tempo di guardare il
cielo lo sapete che i satelliti sono
visibili anche ad occhio nudo sono dei
puntini piccoli piccoli piccoli che
vanno veloce veloce veloce
quelli rossi no quelli sono e renault
e magari vedrete una stella cadente
anche bella grossa con una scia bella
luminosa ecco c'è una grande probabilità
che quella non sia una stella cadente
e magari e il satellite riunion oto
competitor che brucia rientrando in
atmosfera
che comunque ci dà l'occasione di
esprimere un desiderio allora fatelo
lanciate lì i vostri desideri alcuni più
sono improbabili più meritano di essere
lanciati io il mio desiderio improbabile
oggi proprio perché sto qui a modena ve
lo devo dire
il mio desiderio improbabile ed avere
vasco che canta sulla mia rampa di
lancio
grazie